you can see how Bitcoin has pretty much
completed the Sunday projection they
attacked the week to the downside right
at the start of the week that's a false
move okay they failed this week under 50
of this week so we can remove
those targets then price reacted very
aggressively to the upside
go above the 50-minute photos time frame
Tesla support that's another long
trigger if you couldn't get in here all
right and then price goes and attacks
the week to the upside okay so that's
another Target that is done so those two
weeks that we've been talking about for
quite some time and we've been talking
about this idea of quick to Greek has
already happened so what is next
what pretty much we have in my opinion
here
a new week all right you can check out
this week now let me go into the one
hour time frame you still have it there
and in a minute 15 minutes time frame
sorry
you've also got it there all right so
let's go back to the photo time frame
because we are based in a prediction
between for today and tomorrow for the
rest of the week so
what is important is this week over here
has already been felt the 50 right so
you could technically remove it from
your chart I'm not going to because I
like to know what's the what's the low
in the chart all right so that's when I
stay there now
we have this week so let's mark it
all right this could be the 100 and then
the 50 would be
around there all right
so those are the two levels let me get
them there
okay and 50 percent
of the week so we have a new friend in
the chat we have this week now what's
likely to happen next well as you guys
know tomorrow we have CPI data that's on
Thursday and then the next day on Friday
we also have PPI data all right so both
of them are inflation data so the week
is going to get also quite interesting
from from tomorrow
usually
the day before I made your news
announcements like say fomc meeting or
CPI data it's quite normal to see price
consolidating
okay so that's why today I'm not going
to expect much going on here we've
already had an aggressive move here
and of course this pump in in literally
uh two days all right so the most likely
thing is that today in my opinion we
consolidate and there is not much going
on now if you are a day trader
you're probably gonna have to go into
the 15 minutes time frame
okay and you're gonna have to start
looking for the structures here that's
what I would probably tell you
um you can see that price for example is
respecting quality 15 minutes time frame
50ma so again if this continues holding
and you see price going down then you
know you can take some longer scalps
very small scalps but that's an area all
right of course we're gonna keep an eye
on the week because this week is going
to get filled it's gonna get filled
today or
tomorrow
to meet the question for this week is
are we gonna be able to hold the range
lows check this out guys this is your
range range highs range lows mid-range
and we've been consolidating below the
range to lose for quite some time and we
were saying that we found every
suspicious that you know within
consolidating below resistance for quite
some time testing the 458 the valley
50ma and we couldn't see a sell-off so
that was telling us that it was very
likely to see a short squeeze to the
upside and it just happened okay so now
to me the question is we've just got
above the range lows
are we gonna close the quickly above the
range flows or again below the rain
slows
asked me the question
um whatever happens that's when I also
make an impact on my next week analysis
okay because if we close above the range
lows and we tested our support then
we're gonna continue favor and higher
prices all right and if we close below
the range lows then maybe we can see
some more blood going on and maybe
finally test this potential Support over
here
at 28 200.
okay
so that's what I have in my mind right
now I'm just waiting to see what happens
tomorrow I'm not expecting much going on
today the day before CPI usually you
usually don't see much going on okay
guys and tomorrow
we could see the midweek reversal if CPI
comes hot or comes shorter than expected
and before that then that's when you
could see this week getting filled
okay because if we drop from here
aggressively now without failing this
week but when I'm in the same place as
here
okay we're gonna come here then
and I'm gonna tell you hang on
don't pull your shorts so fast because
we still have a walk to the upside so if
you want to favor shorts what you want
to see is that either today or tomorrow
you want to see this we're getting
filled then you want to see a dump and
you want to see the weekly candle
closing below the range loose
okay that's what you want to see in
order to favor to favor shorts otherwise
at least swing shorts all right of
course you know you can you can open
some day trades shorts up here in this
okay I'm just trying to see if you can
find a reaction from there to the
downside
but if you are looking for showing
shorts ideas this is now a place to open
a swing shop because right now you are
again above the rain size and if we
manage to close above the rain size and
test their supporters
you have a lot of continuation here you
could even go above this high and go to
32k where we saw some liquidity
yesterday in hablo Capital all right so
keep an eye on
especially tomorrow
CPI data let's see what happens what my
idea is that today Market should go
sideways should be boring I mean what do
you expect that is look at that what
we've seen already this week a lot of
action so if you have adhesive sideways
it's okay you know it's okay
and then tomorrow is we would see some
more movement some more volatility with
the CPI data so that's pretty much
everything guys let me check now hybrid
Capital because I know that it's getting
quite interesting over there so let's
check it out
Capital guys
a lot of things happen here first of all
if you remember yesterday's video there
was a massive Spike of liquidity check
this out this is this one at 29 958
they hated yesterday with that week okay
so that soon is it uh sadly I guess that
a lot of short positions have been
liquidated
but this is the market guys all right
this is this is the market so so what do
we have now in the liquidation levels
well first of all the delta we have let
me check
over 10 billion dollars worth of long
liquidations
that means that the position that it's
right now at risk
is the long position all right check
this out right now the race is some kind
of for every one short position there
are three long positions opened that's
the ratio okay there are a lot more
Longs open right now than shorts so then
the position that it's a risk is going
to be locked because if they pull price
now to the downside they're gonna start
to see here this is spikes at the right
they are liquidations okay long
liquidation so you go here for example
let me check
um
I mean to be honest that one is quite
important wow 153 million dollars okay
29 500 you go there
you also got let me see if I get it
there 29 200.
30 years ago 28 600 so there is quality
to the downside
in fact right now the major liquidity
seems to be to the landsat after this
move in the short term but there is also
some more liquidity up there look at
those spikes that is still quite close
to of liquidations so just be mindful
because if even if this is a 10 billion
dollars worth of long liquidations they
could Spike up even higher before coming
back down I would suggest you guys to go
flat into tomorrow's CPI that means that
you don't have any positions open
because you might see some volatility in
the chart and you might not like it okay
it might take you out of the audio
position now seven days time frame
oh that's crazy look how they hit all
those liquidations guys up here at 29
600 ish
and of course yeah thirty thousand one
hundred
it's it's insane how they fit it okay
now if you let me let me get this again
Athena if you check yet to the downside
in the seven days time frame that is not
that many liquidations except the 32k
now for us to favor 32k
we still have to close the quickly
handle above the range lows test it as
support and then get above the mid range
that's around 30 500 I think grab of
that level tested the support and then
go for the highs of the range load of
the range highs and break out with
volume not a lot less time in yesterday
video we talked about that fake volume
okay and to the announce that you have
28 600 right now in the monthly time
frame
I think you want to see 32k here again
okay there you go
so you can see the defeat again this is
some thirty thousand two hundred perfect
is still there is quality to the upside
even a 32k we already know what we want
to see in the chart for us to favor 32k
which matches with that potential
support that I was talking about again
for us to favor this target over here
you want to see the rookie candle
closing below the range laws
okay otherwise
you don't have any confirmation or you
don't have any Confluence to believe
that we're gonna hit all this this level
okay so be very mindful because right
now we are in my opinion
in no man's land okay that's what I
think and and even more considering that
tomorrow we have CPI and we shouldn't
have any positions open until then
um so guys if you've been riding this
long
I will see you to take profit my
position is fully closed it closed at
the week so it's you know and right now
today
I'm just gonna go in lower time frame
five minutes time frame 15 minutes time
frame and if I see any trading setup
like for example a random long week that
we create before the New York session or
something like this then I'll take a
trade otherwise I'm happy to just go
flat into tomorrow okay and and again if
I take a trade today it has to be closed
by tomorrow before CPI so that's pretty
much everything that I think guys thank
you so much for watching and I'll see
you soon